foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing Hogwarts and the four animal
mascots that represent the Hogwarts
house system at Hogwarts there are four
houses Gryffindor Southern Ravenclaw and
Hufflepuff houses created by the
original four founders of Hogwarts
godric Salazar Rowena and Helga why four
houses well put as simply as possible
there were four Founders and each
founder wanted to teach the students in
their own way dividing the students
accordingly seemed like the best course
of action each of the four houses
created by the school's Founders can be
represented in a number of different
ways the first and most obvious
identifier of a Hogwarts house is the
use of their signature colors Slytherin
can be identified by green and silver
Hufflepuff by yellow and black Ravenclaw
by Blue and bronze blue and silver in
the movies
and Gryffindor by red and gold these
colors can be found plastered all of the
common rooms and uniforms of the
respective houses but that's not the
only way to identify a Hogwarts house
the cornerstones of the Hogwarts house
system and perhaps the most iconic
symbols associated with each house are
the house mascots
for Gryffindor this mascot was a line
Slytherin a serpent for Hufflepuff a
badger and for Ravenclaw an eagle or
Raven in the films but what do these
creatures have to do with anything what
connection do they have to the founders
and how did these seemingly mundane
creatures at least looking at it from
the perspective of a magical world get
chosen as representatives for these
houses I've got nothing against Lions
serpents badgers or Eagles but in a
world filled with things like dragons
acromantulas destrals and nundus these
creatures seem less impressive I'm going
to start with why these creatures were
chosen and then move on to why magical
creatures weren't chosen the lion when
it comes to the Hogwarts house animals
it's important that we look beyond their
physical stature and instead shift our
Focus to the symbolism associated with
these different animals to begin let's
kick things off with the line
gryffindor's mascot a king in our own
Animal Kingdom and a creature that is
unquestionably symbolic on a vast number
of levels the Sorting Hat had this to
say of Gryffindor House you might belong
in Gryffindor where dwell the brave of
heart their daring nerve and chivalry
said gryffindors apart
bravery and chivalry those are two of
the most prominent features of
Gryffindor House and it just so happens
that Lions symbolize these two traits
perfectly bravery is in my opinion the
standout quality of Gryffindor students
as we've seen some of the most hesitant
witches and wizards like Ron Weasley and
Neville Longbottom muster up their
courage and stand in the face of Lord
Voldemort and if we look at the element
of chivalry it seems only natural that
the king of beasts and King of the
Mughal Animal Kingdom would be a
suitable choice for a house that
radiates royalty gryffindor's also the
ruling house in the series due to its
connection with the main protagonists
and even its house colors of red and
gold signify royalty but what else do
lions represent Justice in Mesopotamian
mythology Samus also known as The Lion
Man or God of Justice allows King Etna
to free an eagle who's been trapped by a
serpent in this example we can see that
even before Harry Potter the lion eagle
and serpent all animals representing
Hogwarts houses have a shared history
the line against the serpent is a common
theme in folklore that is repeated once
again in Harry Potter pitting Gryffindor
against sutherin
the serpent moving on from the line
we're going to discuss its Nemesis the
serpent or perhaps in Slytherin you'll
make your real friends those cunning
folk use any means to achieve their ends
the general theme in Harry Potter is
that slytherins are conniving ambitious
and willing to do whatever it takes to
succeed even if that means stepping on a
few toes along the way Sutherlands are
also incredibly cunning and often able
to manipulate others and to get what
they want these attributes can all be
seen in their house mascot the snake
which has long been identified with acts
of ambition and cunning in nature snake
show ambition by going after prey much
larger than them and they show their
cunning by using clever tactics to trick
confuse their prey like via camouflage
an early tale outlining the snake's
propensity to deceive is in the story of
Adam and Eve where the snake was able to
convince Eve to give in to Temptation
and to pick fruit from the tree
however the biggest reason for salazars
that they're in choosing this house
mascot was undoubtedly his unique
connection to snakes for you see Salazar
Slytherin was a parcel mouth a wizard
that had the innate ability to talk to
snakes it seems only fitting that he
should dedicate his house to the
creature he closely resonated with
the badger next up we've got the badger
the mascot of house Hufflepuff
you might belong in Hufflepuff where
they are just and loyal those patient
hufflepuffs are true and unafraid of
toil Hufflepuff is similar to Gryffindor
in that they both value Justice and
aren't afraid to show a bit of Bravery
but one of the big differences is that
they're a little more reserved in their
approach the badger though Fierce and
Powerful has quite a reserved
disposition commonly leading a quiet
life and not revealing its true ferocity
until provoked in some ways this
reflects the way that the other three
Hogwarts houses view Hufflepuff
Hufflepuff is commonly written off a
joke an afterthought but in truth they
were the second most represented house
during the Battle of Hogwarts and have
achieved more than their fair share of
success badges are quite common in
children's literature playing prominent
roles in stories Like the Wind in the
Willows and the animals of farthing wood
in these Tales each of these badges
perfectly exemplify what it is to be a
Hufflepuff In The Wind in the Willows
Badger shows incredible loyalty to his
friends no matter how much they test his
patience and in the animals of farthing
wood the badger reveals its nurturing
caring nature and traits we know to be
consistent with the house founder Helga
the eagle but first let's address the
elephant or Raven in the room
ravenclaw's house mascot is not a raven
it's an eagle you may be able to find
all sorts of Ravenclaw merchandise
online with a raven on it but in truth
ravenclaw's mascot was only changed for
the films in the books which are true
Canon Ravenclaw house is represented by
an eagle as well as the colors blue and
bronze rather than blue and silver or
yet in Wise Old Ravenclaw if you've
already mined where those of Whitten
learning will always find their kind the
overarching character trait associated
with Ravenclaw is undoubtedly
intelligence or wisdom and in this
regard they couldn't have picked a
better mascot the eagle while also a
symbol of strength and immortality is
deeply rooted as a symbol for
intelligence wit and High Spirit this is
reflected in the Ravenclaw student
welcome message our emblem is the eagle
which saws where others cannot climb and
if we look at the prevalence of eagles
in myth we can find even more evidence
that Eagles are synonymous with wisdom
in Mesopotamian folklore the eagle is
double-headed representing its ability
to see in both directions at the same
time and emphasizing its association
with wisdom doesn't get much clearer
than that with the above explanations
hopefully have provided you with a
better idea of why these muggle animals
were chosen to represent each house in
lieu of magical creatures ilvermorny may
have houses named after magical beasts
but that school was founded by different
people in a different part of the world
in a different era Thunder the birds
Wampus cats horn serpents and Puck
wedgies are impressive and they seem to
work well as house mascots but these
creatures were also chosen fairly
arbitrarily when ilvermorny was formed
the founders simply chose their favorite
magical Beast to represent the houses
and didn't make their decisions based on
any kind of deeper Connection in this
way I think the Hogwarts houses are a
lot more special furthering this the
houses at ilvermorny are looked at as
pieces of a hole where Hogwarts houses
have entirely their own identities
existing independently from one another
it is sometimes said of the ilvermorny
houses that they represent the whole
witch or wizard the mind is represented
by horned serpent the body Wampus the
heart pakwaji and the Soul Thunderbird
in essence the only reason that magical
creatures weren't chosen was because
they weren't necessary they could have
chosen more impressive creatures sure
but the choices made by the original
four founders of Hogwarts were made for
a reason we also have to remember that
Hogwarts was founded before the
international statute of secrecy had
been put in place meaning that Muggles
and Magic folk coexisted during this
time due to exposure to the Muggle World
these muggle creatures could have become
near and dear to the founders and one
last Theory to close off this video
since this is Harry Potter theory is
that the animals associated with each
house were representative of the
Hogwarts Founders Patronus animals
according to Harry Potter law the animal
shape of the Patronus is determined by
the personality of the cast air and
based on this we can safely assume that
the characteristics that this person
displays are characteristics they share
in common with that animal the only
issue with this theory is that I'm not
sure whether Salazar Slytherin would
have been able to produce a Patronus and
that's it for this video did you ever
ask yourself of these questions got any
more for me leave a comment down below
as always if you enjoy the content
please be sure to like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
[Music]